we're in a race against the Nazis
I know what it
[Music]
'd be hello everyone my name is
Jacqueline Coley and welcome to the big
ticket interview for Universal Pictures
oftenheimer I am joined by the cast and
filmmakers hello everyone welcome okay
uh Mr Christopher Nolan sir I have to
start with you because I love the
Inception of this film yes I did do that
because it sprung forth from your pages
of tenet and I love the idea that that
line sort of gave birth to this
hyper-realistic tale that gets told
across 11 miles of 70 millimeter film
like that's just kind of crazy yeah well
I've been interested in Oppenheimer for
some time and we put it into it as a you
know an analogy but this idea of the
moment where Oppenheimer and his team
couldn't entirely rule out the idea that
when they let off that first device
they'd start a chain reaction that would
destroy the world that just seemed like
the most incredible moment in time to
take the audience to be in that room
with them
one of the things I love with it too
because how incredible the story is is
you take a 20-year collaborator and put
him in his like a lead role with this
one but how quickly in that process did
you Center in on Killian as the person
to betray him because he's just such a
paradoxical man such a conundrum sitting
here I kind of maybe get it maybe that
was part of it something that you saw
and you can ship with him but yeah when
did you did you select him for the part
you know I when I'm writing I try to be
disciplined and not right
with actors in mind because then you're
writing something you've already seen
them do and it's limited but when you
finish the script then for me I was
adapting the book American Prometheus
the book sitting there
with the real Robert Oppenheimer staring
out with this incredible sort of
blue-eyed stare from the cover of that
book and I thought well I know who could
do that and uh I've been lucky enough to
work with Gillian for 20 years now yeah
and uh but never in a leading role and
this time I got to to make that call and
say yeah this is the one you're going to
take set of stage and you get to really
carry the audience with you on this
journey
there's something to be said for your
eyes Sir in this picture I'm just going
to put that out there we've seen those
first look images for a long time that's
all we had was just a picture of your
face in this costuming you see how I
just got out of his light
but but I will say for you I loved
reading how that phone call because
again you guys have worked together I
mean to go from shivering Soldier to to
this moment I just love that you have a
relationship that can play out in this
many chapters but for you what was it
like like again just take us to that
phone call and knowing that you're gonna
get to do this I mean that was one of
the great days you have a few of those
in your career and that was that's been
the best so far I mean this typical
Chris fashion there's no like text or
Preamble I might be writing something
just came straight out of the blue so it
was a shocker yeah but like the best
type of shocker you know
um I love this too because all of you
maybe get that shock moment I guess you
maybe text or calls all of you to get
that texting no texting sorry yeah no
texting excuse me I don't know why I got
so digital who am I talking to yeah even
an analog here but for you Mr Robert
Downey Jr sir I have to say this role I
I I'm just I have to say after Decades
of watching you play a hero seeing you
go up against
Oppenheimer as Strauss it's been so
incredible and I loved Chris talking
about how you got to just lose yourself
in it did you like losing yourself in a
bit of a slippery character if I have to
say
yeah I love a good uh protagonist just
to double up on Killian's mine was I
read the script I was mind blown and
then Chris said will you do it
so we're getting texts and all that cuts
right to the chase but there is
literally that's called a director he's
very direct and it's why everything like
you said Matt by the time I got to set
you said Downy everything happens in
front of the camera you're going to love
this you said to me Emily said I'm
telling you this is going to be a
life-changing experience of course he
already knew but then he was in front of
it and that was the real Joy was to show
up for someone we all admire and watch
him carry this ball across the yeah I do
have to say what you see on screen just
your performance after seeing you again
in maybe digital format your face needs
70 millimeter in this performance all of
your faces need 70 millimeter on the
screen for what you guys are doing it's
absolutely incredible and you've
assembled this cast but I have to say
Emily I know that you wanted to work
with Christopher Nolan and re-team with
Killian but peaky blinders and your love
for it just had to factor in because
he's got a hat
he does look good he does do a hat very
well but coming into this one what I
really folks I think are going to find
out is how incredible Kitty was and what
we don't know about her because we get
to explore her in a way I've seen some
of the other portrayals of the Manhattan
Project we see her in a way we've never
seen before was that what sort of
brought you into the character it was
Chris's script it was an extraordinary
part she's a fireball and complicated
and not the archetypal sort of
conformist of 50s housewife you know
he's her fourth husband at 29. yeah
um but I I think they were like
like comets coming together and she was
clearly a Monumental presence in his
life but not an easy woman
um
[Music]
I read this line in American Prometheus
that Chris encouraged us to read and it
said she didn't do small talks she only
did Big Talk and it was so emblematic of
the character really but
I mean I just had the best dialogue and
the best scenes and I think my scenes
were Killian with very emotional and
wrought and and exciting it's where you
see the the intimacy of this man you see
the private life and the trauma of a
brain like that and it was just so
exciting to get to work with kill again
and we I'd loved working with him on
quiet place too and I think having that
trust and secret language we already had
established was huge you know jumping
into this world of tempestuous couple I
remember Chris saying when we did the
camera test we were in our Prosthetics
and Chris went God I never want to have
them over for a dinner
oh my God I didn't want the oppenheimers
but you would feel obligated to invite
him you'd have to like no and you know
it would get messy Auntie Perry I'm
sorry I'm just going to be sitting with
that for a minute uh what's so
interesting is the people that were
surrounded by the great man as much as
he was doing what he they were integral
to him doing what he did and your
character I think is another one of
those interesting things that are around
him as another leader in the Manhattan
Project but he was such an interesting
Ally because he was part of that
conservative Soldier movement that was
going up against these liberal
scientists but y'all have probably the
strongest relationship in the end of
this that's again talk about that
balance that you had with the character
and with their friendship yeah I mean to
Echo what Danny was saying
um Chris is very direct like when he
offered me Interstellar years ago he
said you know they say there are no
small parts there are only small actors
and I'm on the FICO yeah and he goes
this is a small Park
so
when he came back
and and he said you know the book is
American Prometheus it's this great
Pulitzer Prize winning book he goes I'm
not calling the movie that I'm calling
it Oppenheimer because it has to be
entirely it is going to be through his
eyes and when I read the script I'd
never seen this before it was written in
the first person never seen that before
and it gave you as a reader the the that
visceral that's subjective Oppenheimer
experience so instead of going
Oppenheimer across to the window it says
I I walk towards the window and you're
you know and it's just had this kind of
immediate seeing kind of visceral punch
and so you could see what he was trying
to communicate to us and to his crew
like this is what the movie's gonna be
and he said what I need are actors in
support of that this entire thing is
going on Killian's back and I need you
guys to support that right and so that
was really that's a great kind of
marching orders very you know actionable
for us and and easy to understand and
every day I was like all right how can I
help that
um how can I get more
but but watching the two of them because
it really is a partnership at that level
when you see a movie at this scale that
is fearless enough to live in Quiet
Moments in you know in IMAX on his face
and with everything that's going on I
mean the most impossible moral
quandaries and you know and and live
there it's about these two guys being so
locked in together and and watching them
build that together and then watching
Chris build a movie around that
performance was was the rush so in my
case it was yeah you know I'm one of the
spokes of the wheel and the tension
between us is that is that you know the
military is obviously obsessed with
secrecy and compartmentalization and as
you say the liberal scientists are like
you know open the kimono let's share all
of our our knowledge so that we can get
to the answer and so there was this kind
of natural tension but despite that
these two guys actually really liked and
respected each other even though nobody
else liked Grove
the fun thing to play
you just didn't give a
and it would be liked it was so far down
on his list of objectives like if you
ask him like do people like you he would
probably look at you like I don't even
understand the question you know what I
mean because what they were doing was so
consequential I mean Chris has said he's
been on record saying oppen armor is the
most important person to live uh in the
last hundred years if not ever and this
movie is about the most important things
human beings did
perhaps in the in you know in the
history of the species and so to be part
of a movie that's telling that story
with the director who's at the absolute
height of his abilities you know with
with a chance to support that
performance which to me is one of the
Great Performances I've ever seen on
screen was thrilling so and this is from
the man who colonized Mars
I was all I had no Supporting Cast
potatoes just the potatoes were giving
you a lot
it's incredible listening to the Cavs
talk about because I've seen the film
and it is like that you want to discuss
it and you want to have a moment with it
beyond that and I think this is a film
that begs you to see it on the biggest
screen possible with the best sound but
beyond all the visuals and sort of
cinematic things I think it's the fact
that afterwards you need to talk to
people like last night I'm outside of
Lincoln Center and I'm like calling home
I'm like we need to discuss this and did
you have that similar experience when
you saw it like I just I want to take
into folks because I know you all
created this but the visual experience
of seeing it I know you couldn't even
grasp that on set possibly I think
uh Mr Nolan Maestro is a a singular
Storyteller in that all of his movies
even at you know the most obvious one
being the spinning top at the end of
Inception it's always inviting
conversation he's always presuming the
audience wants to be elevated to a place
where there's a dialogue that continues
on and then this is kind of the natural
progression you know and I think about
like what was Kubrick doing before he
decided to make you know pick one of his
films and you just you're just glad that
there is this progression but yeah for
sure I mean we're excited by it and it's
it's a roller coaster of just an
experience cinematically but it also is
that thing that I think that's why
you're responding the way you are you
know we want we want to be challenged by
cinema at its best I can only think of
the challenge that you were faced with
this portrayal um I first of all I'm
glad to see you here you looked so
sickly on screen
I wanted to give you
we were all in New Mexico like eating
quesadillas and he was like in his room
eating an almond by the way he declined
every dinner invitation for the entire
film we invited him dinner every night
he never came once I mean that's a
commitment
the only thing Chris would do by Texas
his daily calorie count oh my gosh
that's getting real let me let me bring
it back a little
a little character and knowing that this
was a man that had so much written about
him you have to make him still real you
still have to make him someone you can
live and breathe in and I think for
every actor they talk about there's a
moment where it switches it stops being
the research and the script and it
starts just being something you embody
what was that moment for you was it on
set was it a pre-production well the
approach I always take is do as much
research as you possibly can and there's
so much out there about Oppenheimer and
the Manhattan Project is there's so much
archival footage out there you can you
can access and you know obviously I read
the book but for me the most important
resource was this script you know that's
what I really worked on and I had six
months from when Chris called me
unexpectedly and to when we started
shooting to work on it having said that
I think when you get on the floor with
actors like these guys and with Chris
you kind of just put that aside and it
all becomes kind of about the moment and
the truth and the emotion between the
the actors and that was just every day
it was it was a gift you know I can't
give you one specific point but there
was many scenes in the film like with
Robert and when Emily and with Matt like
they were just kind of electric you
could kind of feel it fizzing and at
that point yeah it isn't intellectual
it's kind of instinctual and emotional
well the proof will be in the pudding
when folks get to see it again I I don't
want to say this because I was lucky
enough to see it last night in Lincoln
Center on like that incredible screen
where like literally the seats Shook at
certain points of explosions but I have
to say I would feel cheated I know
everyone says this but I'm like no you
kind of I want everyone to have that I
was sitting dead center on the very back
row I want everyone to have that
experience I like for you sir Mr Nolan
to explain
some of the deliberate things you made
in filming this choosing to film it in
IMAX the first film to do it completely
well to while you did I think what 80 on
Dunkirk and now this one is completely
in that ratio there's visual effects and
moments in the film that beg that and I
know that you crafted it that way I
would love for you to talk about some of
those moments that you made specifically
to really sort of envelope this format
and to expand it in ways that we haven't
seen before well I've used IMAX for
years and it IMAX film is is the highest
quality Imaging format ever devised and
what that gives you is access to the
audience's perceptions it takes the
screen away I refer to it as sort of 3D
without the glasses you know you're just
looking at a crystal clear sharp image
and we've used it in the past for a lot
of action
um we've used it for the grand Vistas
and my Director of Photography
and myself you know we knew we would get
New Mexico that way we would get the
storms we would get the desolation of
where they they built Los Alamos but
what we both got really excited about is
how can it
how can this format help
give us access to oppenheim's thought
process how can it help us really peer
into his soul you know how what happens
when you apply that ground format to
intimacy to what these guys are doing
you know to to Really seeing the world
through his eyes and trying to pick up
the different layers of of what
everybody is thinking and feeling and
all of the conflicts and uh paradoxical
situations and unethical dilemmas that
are going on and we found that the
format is a powerful tool for all
aspects of of Cinema really and Cinema
is just about storytelling and it's more
than anything about the human arm again
yeah the human element is definitely I
think a big part of that one again we
talk about the interesting questions or
folks that have seen the trailer this is
going to come out before they get a
chance to see the film the question that
you sort of jokingly make in the trailer
and that Chris talked about like this
idea that could Set Fire To The World
becomes a much bigger question when you
actually look at the film and and as it
goes to it was that originally from that
script because I have to imagine as an
actor like that's that's it that's you
don't really did you like so it's like
how how did they do that
but the like I love like like downy's
character he's obsessed with this
conversation that these two great
scientists have it's like it's about the
bigness and greatness of men in this in
women in the smallness of us you know
what I mean like human beings are just
so
you know so yes to your point like it is
it it it it it
it's there's a reason he wrote about it
in tenant there's a reason it's in our
movie it's because it's it's kind of a
central conundrum like how how they
press the button anyway how would you do
that if there was any possibility
yeah you could wipe the species
like how do you press the button and
they were taking bets on it yeah that's
the crazy thing that's also what I think
though how do you approach that day you
have to treat that when we talk about
layers you have to give the absurdity of
them taking bets the reality of what he
is saying and then also the cinema of
playing that out between these two
characters I just want to talk about
that scene between the two of you well I
just also say the the the the the
incredible Brilliance of Opera
Oppenheimer but yet his naivete right to
go to to think that this this is going
to end perhaps end all wars there's a
moment in the movie that I love which is
when the genie is out of the bottle and
Oppenheimer realizes that he has no
control of it when he comes and says to
me should I come to Washington and I
look at him and I go why and you just
realize oh my God they're done with him
you know now now this thing is a reality
and it exists in the world and he and he
he's he has no control over it and yet
in his own kind of innocence and
beautiful way you know he was the only
person who could have helped create it
but
kind of thought it might be a force for
good and like what a naive way
ridiculous thought in retrospect but
what a you know it's it's so tragic and
so kind of beautifully human at the same
time playing that moment
um there's so much your character goes
through through the course of this his
perspective on things that were closely
attached to his very being he changed
his mind about and and again this idea
of a polyglot poet who created this
weapon of mass destruction he lives in
those contradictions how did you
reconcile that in the performance
because he's not conflicted as he's
doing it he's almost stoic in his
decisions but we know that he is
literally battling battles within
himself yeah totally well I mean we were
kind of trying to play the kind of
interior I suppose you know it was it
was to internalize the performance a lot
I think that's what we're certainly
trying to do and you know certainly with
all those
amazing close-ups that Chris
uses with the on the IMAX camera yeah
but that's that they're the brilliant
characters you know the ones that have
the huge complexity and ambiguity and uh
contradictions and I don't know we just
kind of had to plot our way through it
particularly when you're shooting out of
order as well you know trying to figure
it all out where he stood emotionally
and morally at each point in the story
is very very complex certainly the most
complex character I've ever approached
yeah you told us a few weeks ago that
there was something he said which I
loved about that he's a chess player and
not a box I was that was yeah that was
in a scene we had yeah remember that
that was early on and I think I came in
a bit heavy in that scene and you said
to me yeah Kelly's not a he's not a
boxer he's a chesper that's just an
example of one of the unbelievably
versions total permission as an actor by
the way to just let the entire thing
come to you but it just can turn a
performance like completely on its own
one sentence can just yeah pretty good
at that yeah well that's very kind of
you say but the thing about that not
shooting in order and you having to
figure out that puzzle for yourself yeah
and you know I'm there on set trying to
gauge that for the audience some of the
sort of audiences yeah eyes on set
um but it's really not until we're
getting the edit sweet and sit there
with Jen Lane who's cutting the film and
then we see what all you've done and it
starts to fit together and you see the
work that's gone in uh because I get to
take that for granted when I work with
people they turn up the set they do
their thing it seems simple it often
seems effortless
and then you get in the Etta Suite you
see how it relates to something an hour
away in the film and that's where you
start to see the work that these guys
have put in I think it's a testament to
just listening to everybody sort of like
geek out on what you guys did on set but
also just the fact that everyone got to
be a part of him and in this cast is
incredible and I think it's a testament
to you you have frequent collaborators I
think five Oscar winners eight nominees
total like this is a cast that is very
stacked but the selection process is
equally as hard I mean some of the
smallest roles when I look at them I'm
like yeah that's a perfect casting for
that creepy character or that like
intriguing character what is your sort
of guiding force when you're when you're
making these selections because again
this is not these are people that are
part of the annals of History I just
look at somebody like how did you see
that Betty safti could play yeah
well Benny I mean I I call Paul Thomas
Anderson he Benny had just done licorice
pizza and I'm a big fan of Benny as a
director and you know I call Paul and
like how before I'd seen the film you
know what do you think and he's like
he's the best you'll you'll love him he
was absolutely right and Benny you know
when I met Benny it became clear that he
had almost become a physicist he
literally had a moment in his life where
he's like it's physics or it's you know
filmmaking and so this was sort of
everything
no he's he was fabulous but the the
thing I had done at script stage is I
decided it's a risk and you know I'm
hoping the audience uh enjoys this I
didn't make composite characters so we
have a lot of people got a lot of young
new faces we've got a lot of stuff going
on and you're trying to cast people with
a particular energy that's memorable and
fits the character and I work with my
casting director John pepsodera since
Memento
um and so he's brilliant at just finding
all kinds of choices
um and I get in the room with actors I
try to cast in person not you know not
doing it all remotely and everything and
you try to sort of feel the energy of
those people and you get you know
somebody like you know old and Aaron
Reich who comes and and
together it just brings so much to the
film yeah uh Emily I definitely want to
talk about this because one of the few
scenes where we get to see you know
Robert Oppenheimer emotion with any
emotion has to do with you and I love
the fact that she was his ride or die
there's no other way to put it like this
was the person he was meant to be with
but she also is the person quickest to
like call him out on his BS also and I
love that you got to play that like this
is
I don't know that yet but I think I'll
find out
yeah I'll find out but yeah talk about
that like just how she was the only one
that's I don't care if you're the father
of the atomic bomb step up
yeah I think particularly kind of at the
you know later on in the movie and
during the hearings I think his passive
approach must have just infuriated her
and you see it infuriate her because
there's a directness and a forcefulness
to the character and conviction she's
got real conviction about everything
from drinking to you know being hard on
him and so
I think that that's where you see the
storm of the relationship start to kind
of build but you see the loyalty and the
fight that she has for him and
um I think she worshiped him I think she
thought he was incredible and
yeah I think those scenes have impact in
the film because she's maybe one of the
only people who will just say what
everyone else wishes they could you know
um unfortunately again I feel like I
could spend another 30 minutes just
talking about the crafts of this film I
want to spend an hour talking to your
editor I don't know what you put him or
her through but they have done all of
the things with this one uh it's
absolutely incredible but I have to talk
about the visual effects the special
effects and the realism that everyone
knows that you're committed to I mean
just how big was the bomb like I just
wanted like just
a lot
that's a hard thing to answer without
giving away giving away the tricks the
visual effects Supervisor was first
person after Emma my producer that I
showed the script to because I said to
him you know I want you to take computer
Graphics off the table and think long
and hard in over a series of months do
some experiments and figure out ways and
in which we can show organized interior
State his visualizing of atomic behavior
of quantum physics and then carry that
threat right the way through to its
ultimate expression in the extreme
Beauty and Terror of the Trinity test
the first time that human beings saw
nuclear energy released in that form and
so he worked long and hard on some
things that were very very small and
some things that were very very big and
we got out there in that desert with
these guys and you know we went through
our own sort of mini version of that
Trinity test where you're you're all out
there in the desert in the middle of the
night in your bunkers very very focused
on what's going to happen and making
sure that it's being done safely and
carefully but done on a on a suitably
grand scale I've so who was on set that
day Matt and so as an actor that day
there's no acting needed right like I
call it Nar no acting required
you just show up you put on your your
wardrobe and you go on out and Yeah
enjoy the show
it's that moment but I'd have to ask you
killing because again that
is probably the moment I knew about
Oppenheimer before I read the book
before I knew anything was just his
quote and him watching that project what
was that day moment like for you yeah I
kind of agree with Matt I think you just
have to I don't remember us talking very
much on that that evening or those few
nights that we were out because you're
aware of what this means and what
actually went down and how like the
world changed completely from what
happened there so again it goes back to
what I was saying earlier it wasn't a
kind of an intellectual approach it was
more of just like an emotional approach
because we all knew I think everybody
when we were out there those nights in
the desert kind of knew what we were
portraying
so you're also putting yourself in that
head that headspace yeah that that the
anxiety like what must have been I I I
the most profound anxiety fear you know
hope every everything that they had
riding on this
um you know it was years of their lives
it was billions of dollars like just
that's what Groves thinking right he's
probably thinking about how much it cost
but you know they're also thinking wait
a minute we might end civilization yeah
again the questions this film it's just
a paradox and dilemmas and everything is
so contradictory you asking a lot I
think of the audience um in the sense
like what they're going to see they're
going to be asking a lot of themselves
afterwards they're going to definitely
have questions I'm just curious for you
sir I have to Envision you have audience
in your mind you've thought about maybe
what they would say after they leave the
cinema and start talking about it what
questions do you hope they're asking
because again this is just his story but
it also I think allows room for the
audience to take it where they want and
I think that's kind of interesting about
it too so is there a place that you hope
they go I don't like to be too specific
about these things not making a
documentary or a didactic statement or
sending a specific message to me the
most interesting cinematic stories they
involve you in the characters dilemmas
they take you on that journey and then
if those stories have something to them
and this is one of the great dramatic
stories of all time I think it leaves
you with resonances interesting
questions ways in which you interacts
with our own lives and the way you know
we live our lives and what we worry
about and what we care about but no I
don't want to be too specific about it I
wanna it's more as Killian was saying
earlier it's more of an emotional
approach as an intellectual approach you
have the research you have the history
of the facts of the story but you want
the audience to feel it and you want it
to leave them with a set of Sensations
and feelings I think we'll leave it
there I want to thank everyone for
watching I want to thank all of you and
remind everyone that that Universal's
Oppenheimer will be in theaters July
21st thank you